thank you very much for joining us we
begin in the united kingdom where a
delayed intelligence report on russia
has just been released it says moscow is
attempting to interfere in uk politics
and there is evidence the kremlin has
tried to meddle in elections
it says there's credible information
that russia attempted to influence the
2014 scottish independence referendum
the committee says it's hard to prove
interference in the brexit
referendum in 2016 but the uk was slow
to recognize the threat
and it also warns that russia's cyber
capability is a matter of grave concern
that poses an immediate threat to
britain's national security
live to sonia gallego in london for us
so sonia a report that we've been
waiting for for almost 18 months now
tell us more about what it indicates
about the level of russian interference
in the uk
well it's finally here the 50-page
document here
that was outlined in that press
conference
given by uh the members of the
uh isc the intelligence community that
was looking into this
and it does paint a rather a dismal
picture of
how lax uh the uk government has been in
terms of dealing with this sort of
threat
and that it has been trying to juggle uh
that
with a sort of prosperity strategy
that was in place at the country and
also lays the blame
at successive uh uk governments for not
treating it
as seriously as it should have been that
russia considers the uk to be one of its
top
intelligence targets and that it should
have recognized this off the back of the
2014
uh scottish independence referendum uh
when there were already signs
of russian interference there but it
failed to tackle that at the time and
then going
subsequently into the european union
independence referendum as well
the problem was they didn't see specific
threats but however
what was difficult to gauge and they
said this in the report
was exactly how that disinformation that
was played out across
uh social media platforms uh could have
influenced people they said they can't
can't tell that it would be impossible
to tell how much that affected
that but really it was the fault of the
government at the time
for not taking this strategy seriously
by russia the report sonya says that the
uk was targeted because of its
relationship with the us
how damaging has the interference been
to the uk overall
and what has been done to counter it if
anything
well fully uh precious little if you
listen to what the
uh isc said at the time when regarding
to that
it wasn't so much as that they willfully
wanted
to resist any form of investigation or
any look into how
corrosive russian interference was in
british society but also they didn't
want to know
they didn't want to touch it with as
they put it with a 10-foot
pole the problem is is that this is not
just in terms of electoral interference
of hacking as well but more subtle forms
of interference as well
how uh prominent russians were able to
infiltrate british society
and then created a sort of cottage
industry of uh
really sort of getting into the heart of
british society as well
it came in the form of prominent
russians giving political donors
to political donations to parties such
as the conservative party the ruling
party now
and also in terms of creating this other
uh landscape where they co-opted lawyers
accountants and estate agents into
spreading their influence
what the phenomenon that's known here as
london grad
so really it's not just the sort of
aggressive approach that has been taken
as we've been seen with the hacking not
just in this country but also
with a democratic uh party that happened
in 2016
but also the softer power of that
influence as well
which and and this report lays that
open to say that this the failure to
tackle that has really brought us to the
situation where we are now
at and really that governments need to
tackle this
not just the uk in itself but it needs
to also have
a cross-government and also an
international strategy to deal
with this kind of interference volley
thank you for that sonia gallego live
there in london
and we'll have more reaction and
analysis of this report released today
on russian interference in the uk sonia
thank you very much for the moment